what's up ladies and gentlemen
as you can see by the name of this video
this will be very different than the
videos i usually make
i want to talk about something that has
a very big influence on me
as well as millions of other fans around
the globe i
am of course referring to the podcasting
scene in los angeles california
thanks to joe rogan and some of his
closest friends i've been able to enjoy
thousands of hours of free entertainment
for nearly a decade
unfortunately we are witnessing the end
of an era
now i know most of my subscribers don't
know that much about me so let me tell
you how my journey as a podcast fan
began
this will help explain why i decided to
make this video in the first place
back in 2011 i was working for a company
that cleaned out these
giant industrial sized ovens these ovens
can be found inside factories all over
the united states
while i worked for this company we would
travel all over the country
to states like indianapolis illinois
ohio
west virginia new jersey kentucky
california
and many other states since it was a
company based on the east coast
we would drive to all these different
states to work in these factories unless
it was california
that was the only state we would fly to
now since we spent so much time on the
road
i would have to find things to do when
we were in the work van or in our hotel
room
i can't even begin to tell you how many
hours i spent in that van
we would be working on the road nearly
300 days out of the year
now i love listening to music or
watching movies just as much as the next
guy
but after a while you do get bored i
know i did
therefore i had to find something else
to keep my mind occupied
at this time i believe i had an iphone 3
and on this phone was an application for
podcasts
this is when i first discovered what
they even were i should also say i have
always been a big fan of comedy
ever since i was around the age of 13 i
would watch stand-up comedians like
chris rock
dave chappelle bill burr and so on and
so forth
so as soon as i found out stand-up
comedians had their own podcast shows
i was instantly hooked on phonics and
this is when i found the joe rogan
experience
i've been a fan since brian redband was
on the show and they would film episodes
out of the back of the ice house
finding this show back then was exactly
what i needed in my life
it almost instantly became one of my
favorite things to listen to
in fact i would say it even influenced
me into making videos of my own
even now i would say i listen to more
podcasts than i do music
which is kinda crazy to think about
there was really nothing else like it
out there that you could find for free
now i know one of joe rogan's biggest
influences was the opie and anthony show
but that was not a show that was offered
for free neither was howard stern for
that matter
those shows were on siriusxm and even
some of the other great podcasters did
not have a show quite like joe's
marc maron and adam corolla had big
shows at the time but they were still
doing your interview style shows
the joe rogan experience was very
different it felt very natural
as if you were hanging out with your own
friends one of the main reasons it felt
like
this is because joe would have all of
his best friends on the show
he never brought them on to interview
them either they would all just talk
about whatever they wanted
whenever i would watch or listen to one
of his new episodes i felt like i was a
fly on the wall
it felt like i was listening to my own
friends have a conversation
this is what made the show so great for
me now i will admit i don't listen to
every single episode that is released
but i do see most of them
if you're a big fan like i am then you
will know joe has a handful of friends
that are on his show
nearly once a month if he does one of
his fight companions then he might have
some of his friends on several times
that month
it just depends on how things work out
and this is what led to me becoming a
fan of some of his other friends who are
stand-up comedians like bert kreischer
tom segura joey diaz brian callan
theo vaughn and so many others my
favorite episodes are when joe has on
the og's from back in the day
like his best friends so as soon as
everyone started to realize how
successful joe's show was becoming
they all started shows of their own joey
diaz started the church of what's
happening now
with his sidekick lee syed then brian
callan started the fighter and the kid
with the former ufc fighter brendan
schaub theo
vaughn also has his own show this past
weekend
because of the joe rogan experience i
became a fan of all these other
comedians
and their own respective shows one of
the things i loved about this group of
friends is how they built this community
with one another
but this is all about the change the
stand-up comedy and podcasting scene in
los angeles california will never be the
same
now i will say there are a lot of things
that do factor into all of these changes
before i go any further and speculate on
anything i do want to make sure everyone
keeps this in mind
i am simply an outsider looking in
obviously i don't know any of these guys
in real life
i'm only a fan who wants to give his
opinion on what's happening lately
now if you're watching this video then i
assume you already know joe rogan is
moving out of los angeles
he has already had a new studio made in
texas where he will be living for the
foreseeable future
i was actually watching joe's show right
before i sat down to make the video and
in his most recent episode he sat down
with his friend duncan
and according to joe he says he does not
think giant cities like los angeles are
sustainable
when the city is running great then
things are wonderful
before covent 19 the comedy store was
sold out almost every night
the restaurants were full and the
economy was much better
joe said that's when los angeles can be
a fun city to live in
but he also said when things go bad
there is no sense of community so
joe's leaving for texas since joe was
the glue that was mostly holding the
community together
it has shattered now that he's leaving
this is how much influence he has on the
scene in l.a
once joe's living in texas he won't have
the same access to all the familiar
faces we are used to seeing on his show
his show also won't be on youtube for
much longer
now that he has signed the big deal with
spotify his show will be uploaded there
starting in december now he will still
upload some of his clips to youtube
but it won't be his full episodes like
it has always been
now i'm sure joey diaz theo vaughn bert
krasher and many of joe's other friends
will still do the show
but it won't be like it was they won't
be able to stop in at the drop of a hat
like they used
to when they have a comedy show to do in
texas i'm sure they will appear on the
show
but that might only be a handful of
times a year the joe rogan experience
will still be a fun watch as always but
i am afraid it will not be the same
how often do you really see joey diaz
booking a flight to texas just to do the
podcast
he doesn't even like driving across la
to do someone else's show
let alone flying across the country how
often will brendan schaub and eddie
bravo be able to join joe for his fight
companions once he's in texas
i don't know about you but i love when
eddie bravo is on the show
even when he's talking about his
conspiracies i love it
unfortunately i don't think eddie will
be on the show that often anymore
i did hear that joe rogan made joey diaz
some kind and offered to move to texas
with him
but for whatever reason joey diaz
obviously declined
and it looks like joey diaz has already
moved out of los angeles
last night on joe rogan's show he said
he talked to joey who already was back
in his home state of new jersey
as of right now joey diaz's show the
church of what's happening now
is over his sidekick lee syat has left
los angeles as well
i think he said he was moving to
milwaukee for a little while then moving
back to boston
so even when joey diaz does bring the
show back
it won't be the same as it was now i
know that some fans of the church do not
like lee
but i don't agree with that at all i
think he's actually a lovable guy
and whether you like him or not he was a
part of the show and now he's gone as
well
now you have to wonder what joey diaz's
show will look like whenever he brings
it back
i'm sure joey will still have great
stories to tell like he always does
but will he be able to get people to fly
to new jersey to be on the show the days
of us seeing all the la comedians
joining their friends on their shows
will be far
and few in between the fighter and the
kid is another show that is almost
unrecognizable as of right now brendan
shaw is still hosting the show but it
doesn't look like brian callan will be
coming back
ever for those of you that don't know
brian callan is one of joe rogan's best
friends
they've been friends ever since the 90s
and in fact
joe rogan has even called brian his
brother as of right now
brian callan is in some hot water ever
since some recent accusations have come
out against him
obviously i wasn't there so i don't know
what happened between them
all i know is this does not look good
for brian
ever since those allegations came out he
hasn't been seen on the fighter in the
kid
or joe rogan's show as far as i know he
has been dropped by everyone
his agent let him go his manager let him
go and so on and so forth
now this is only a guess but i think he
hasn't been on the fighter on the kid
for a few different reasons
for one the comment section would
obviously eat him alive
they already have been even when he's
not on the show but i'm sure they would
lose all their sponsors as well
brian and brendan tried to make a new
show called the fighter in the ranks
which was a patreon exclusive but that
did not last very long either
i can only assume brendan's agent
manager lawyer or whoever told him it
might not be a good idea to host a show
with brian callen right now
so as you can see for one reason or
another some of joe rogan's closest
friends have already stopped creating
shows
before he even left los angeles as of
right now
the church of what's happening now is
over the fighter and the kit is over
now it's just the former fighter and
some random comedian
another well-known la comedian and
podcaster crystalia
has been silent for several months as
well he has also had many different
allegations come out against him
he hasn't uploaded anything or been seen
on anyone's show since
june or early july now if brian or dalia
are guilty of those accusations
then they deserve to be held accountable
but until i have all the facts i will
reserve
my judgment for a later day i do however
wonder if any of this influenced joe
rogan's decision to leave la
not only has comedy been cancelled in
the city but a lot of the comedians he
surrounds himself with are getting
cancelled as well
even if this has nothing to do with him
leaving he has to be thinking everything
is collapsing around him in los
angeles theo vaughn is another one from
this circle of friends who is leaving
the city
as far as i know he will be moving to
nashville very soon
now that all these comedians are moving
away from each other this will
definitely have an effect on all their
shows
they will no longer have access to the
same caliber of people they once had
the comedy store in los angeles will
also suffer because of this
before kovan they had an insane lineup
almost every single night
but now a lot of their headliners will
be spread out across the united states
like i said i'm sure they will still be
able to go on each other's shows every
now and then
but it will not be the same i may be
speaking for myself here but i am not a
fan of the shows they do over zoom
or skype or whatever it is they use it
doesn't have the same feeling it does
when they're in the same room together
there is a bit of a disconnect when they
aren't able to feed off each other's
energy
like they normally do now as i'm writing
some of this down
joey diaz ended his show last night and
it was kind of sad to see that show as
we know it come to an end
i will be very interested in seeing how
things unfold from here on out
i hope we do get some more insight into
what is actually happening behind the
scenes because
although i do believe covet is one of
the main reasons they are all leaving la
i don't think it's the only reason maybe
they're all starting to feel like the
walls are closing in around them
who knows regardless of what led to this
it does appear to be the end of an era
my friends i will be looking forward to
seeing who joe rogan has on his show
now that he will be in texas like i said
before
i am just a fan who wanted to give their
thoughts on some of the recent
developments
if you're a fan as well let me know what
you think down below
i would love to hear what you have to
say anyways i want to thank everyone for
watching the video
i really appreciate that and i hope all
of you have a great day
i will see you in the next video bye